[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans sa aux cadis bon
début de semaine à toutes et à tous
notre invité claude lise le président de
l'assemblée de la collectivité
territoriale de martinique bonjour que
le lis vous merci aux audits
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors pour commencer nous n'allons pas
nous éterniser là dessus revenons sur
cet incident qui a émaillé la dernière
plénière vendredi dernier johnny jarrah
a produit un communiqué sous l'en-tête
de ensemble pour une martinique nouvelle
où il indique que les droits de
l'opposition selon lui ont été encore
une fois bafouée le porte parole du
conseil exécutif
la dernière marie set lui parle d'une
tentative de prendre de force une
nouvelle fois la parole en plénière
c'est exactement ce qui s'est produit
bon c'est ça la démocratie a été mise
véritablement en cause par l'attitude
d'un élu qui a prétendu imposer une
intervention alors qu'il s'agissait
d'une question concernant une
information de la chambre régionale
c'est l'article l mais 600 12-19
informations il n'y a pas de débat
lorsque la chambre régionale souhaite
qu'il y ait un débat est le stipule dans
la vie qu'elle rend hélas il s'agissait
d'une information j'ai annoncé il y aura
une information de la chambre régionale
qui lui était défavorable c'est pour ça
qu'il a voulu intervenir il n'était même
pas nominé c'est le prix le président la
spl transport a été déboutée d'une
saisine du conseil de la chambre
régionale des comptes et il n'y avait
pas de débat à avoir
d'autant que nous étions fans séance il
restait deux motions importante à voter
pour la martinique une sur les hôpitaux
la santé l'autre sur leur avenir
les problèmes du rhum et je lui ai
proposé non je lui ai proposé de
d'intervenir en questions diverses
et il a voulu imposer une caisse en
bafouant le lait lait blement le
règlement si si si chacun pouvait
conduits comme cela n y aura plus d eau
il voit plus de débat démocratique
et chacun sait les martin guerre voilée
plénière
chacun sait à quel point je prends des
précautions vous sauvegardez les doigts
de l'opposition ce n'est pas de mon fait
si l'opposition est sous représenté
c'est le fait du mode d'élection qui a
été choisi par eux mêmes à l'époque par
l'eau patron lors du débat sur la loi
avec une prime de 2 20%
c'est vrai que nous avions critiqué et
je rappelle que je n'ai pas voté cette
loi mal conçu
inachevé mal rédigée dont ils sont
victimes
alors qu'ils ont été les promoteurs de
nuages a redit que vous président de
l'assemblée que le dise avait avait
refusé de lui donner la parole sur le
sujet en question alors même qu'une élue
de la majorité a pu s'exprimer non c'est
totalement faux il est une élue de la
majorité qui a sans avoir la parole qui
a dit simplement de ti s'agit-il
après vingt deux qui sait si cette île
puisqu'on a dit c'est le président de la
spa le transport le nom de john yalley
identifier ça n'a pas eu la parole et
moi je lui ai fait signe d'arrêter mais
ya pas de paroles et je le répète que
j'ai proposé à monsieur aja de prendre
la parole en questions diverses il
suffisait de laisser voter de motion
il y en avait pour même pas 15 minutes
donc c'est une volonté mais habituel
c'est quelqu'un qui se comporte de
manière un corps est avec souvent des
propos à la limite du tolérable
et là c'est la goutte d'eau qui a fait
déborder le vase et vous vous avez
menacé quelque part de devoir l'expulser
peut-être non non non non non justement
j'avais fait allusion vite je n'ai rien
pu dire que j'en ai le pouvoir de par la
loi
j'ai la police de de l'assemblée mais
que je n'allais pas le faire car c'est
ce qu'ils cherchent à provoquer ils ont
vu que jamais je ne fais ce que leur
patron faisait à la région je ne coupe
pas le micro le micro je laisse les gens
s'exprimer et au sein de la majorité
on me reproche souvent d'être trop
complaisant avec l'opposition mais j'ai
le souci de rétablir les équilibres
ils le savent en privé en général ils me
disent qu'ils sont satisfaits de la
manière de je mène les débats mais là
c'est du cinéma
c'est une des motivations politiciennes
ils essaient d'exploiter un incident et
ternir une plénière au cours de laquelle
je veux dire quand même qu'on a voté la
plupart des questions à l'unanimité et
qui a eu des dossiers importants 21
dossiers de demandes et de l'apn pour
plus de 14 millions et demi des bourses
pour les étudiants la création d'une
société de capital risque et cetera et
cetera d'état de subventions c'était une
plénière extrêmement importante et riche
et on essaie de de faire en sorte donné
mauvaise image de ce qui a été fait en
exploitant jeudi de manière vraiment
bassement politiciennes un incident la
mentale et qui ne ternit l'image de
celui qui a provoqué l'incident alors il
n'y a pas eu d'expulsion mais les deux
motions en question l'une pour défendre
leurs hommes de la martinique l'autre
pour la défense du centre hospitalier
universitaire la martinique ses émotions
été votée mais en l'absence du sens pour
une martinique nouvelle via cette
expulsion met dix façons il faut
expulser en quelque chose sont sortis
mais en ordre dispersé après une
suspension de séance comme louis blues
vous avez dit ont menacé le suspens
parce que vous avez repris parce que
l'individu hurlait littéralement bon
j'ai suspendu j'ai repris vous commencez
donc je crois que dans son groupe on a
essayé de lui faire comprendre que même
qui valait mieux de sortir il y avait eu
des tentatives d'ailleurs de
propositions on est venu me proposer de
donner la parole à à deux personnes de
la majorité dit j'ai dit mais oui mais
en questions diverses
car le président séance sinon il n'a
plus d'autorité ne veut pas de déjuger
alors les motions l'une pour défendre
leurs hommes de la marque chic on sait
que le contingentement du rhum à
l'exportation et sais pas si on peut
dire menacé mais en tout cas glissé de 2
si vous voulez de fait la répartition
vous voulez dire la guadeloupe et la rue
surtout la beauté
l'europe est d'accord pour une
augmentation de 20% de du côté l'argent
mais c'est la répartition de cette
augmentation qui pose problème alors que
tout le monde sait que le solo les seuls
roms qui bénéficie d' 2
appellation l'origine composée de la
hausse et sont les nôtres on sait les
forfaits parler des styles et chez nous
ces dernières années on sait
l'importance de la filière bio canne
sucre rhum ici et notamment ce que le
rhum agricole martiniquais des
conquérants comme parts de marchés à
l'extérieur donc le vote de cette motion
les élus de la ccm ce tronçon en blocs
sont derrière pour soutenir à l'ass est
finie soutenir nos parlementaires qui
reçoit lé 10 albums et je m'en félicite
sous ce point là on fait une démarche
commune on peut dire que ils étaient
unanimes là-dessus et je pense que nous
avons intérêt à être vraiment unanime et
c'est pour ça que j'ai progressé
vis-à-vis l'europe alde e ou du
gouvernement et les deux sont visés avec
l'europe et vous avez du gouvernement
pour que le gouvernement soit ferme et
n'accepte pas d'entrer dans un système
qui laisserait la martinique alors que
nous sommes en pointe que nous avons
même des des éléments d'innovation vous
avez tous confirment attire touristique
même au niveau de distillerie voyez
c'était vraiment une notion importante
pour on peut dire le développement de la
martinique
mais pourquoi une motion pour la défense
du centre hospitalier de alors là aussi
deuxième motion extrêmement importante
pour laquelle on avait envie aussi
d'avoir une unanimité
vous savez le centre hospitalier temps
en péril on peut dire d'une situation
extrêmement grave le déficit important
c'est pas nouveau
le déficit ne cesse de s'aggraver
chronique mais vite
il y a eu depuis des années des années
de des interventions en l'état a
quelquefois réagi par des suppléments
dead par des mesures mais toujours
insuffisante et aujourd'hui je suis
obligé d'aller vite tous connus mais
enfin c'est ça ça nécessite qu'elle
n'est une émission avec elle la menace
partir m les médecins nous tiens écoutez
nous avons eu les médecins moi je les ai
reçus en particulier ils n'en peuvent
plus
beaucoup sont au bord de la démission
il y en a qui partent déjà il ya une
insuffisance de personnel il ya alors
bien sûr on a lu un plateau technique
moderne qui a été ouvert décemment mais
tous l'arrière-plan est dans un état
vraiment lamentable et je crois que
beaucoup de martigny sion des ondées
malades qu'ils vont visiter ils se
rendent compte que ça ne peut pas durer
on ne tient pas compte au niveau des
gouvernements successifs on ne tient pas
compte de tous les surcoûts que nous
avons un supporter et puis ce que
l'hôpital
la commission sous le plan régional nous
sommes obligés d'accueillir des gens qui
viennent de partout dans notre
environnement
il faut savoir que le gouvernement a
demandé au centre hospitalier d'envoyer
des aides d'urgence
alors lors du du passage de l'ouragan
irma et
l'allemand s'en est vanté nous avons
fait en sorte qu'il y ait des aides du
centre hospitalier mais il n'attend pas
du tout donné là les moyens de moins de
moyens supplémentaires
même pour l'heure cette mission
particulière alors on peut dire qu'il ya
maintenant un problème de santé publique
à la marque mais il était important là
aussi dire que nous soyons unanimes pour
conclure que gliese c'est un sujet qui
sera peut-être au coeur des prochaines
assises de l'outre-mer sur décliner
territoire par thank you le gouvernement
entend d'une part consulter la
population faire remonter des
propositions des pistes de développement
de la part de la population et
travailler aussi avec les collectivités
les collectivités locales
l'opération est un exercice purement
formelle parce que nous avons connu des
prêts à vous impliquer sur vous savez on
affame quand même méfiants parce que les
états généraux on en a eu
vous avez vous en avez en mémoire et on
sait que souvent on veut nous faire
passer des dispositions déjà arrêté à
paris donc j'espère que ce sera une
vraie concertation une réelle écoute des
forces vives de la martinique très bien
écouter c'est ce qui met un terme à
notre entretien il est déjà presque 7h29
merci d'avoir participé à ça au caddie
claude lise président de l'assemblée de
la collectivité territoriale de
martinique raison des biens si bien
[Musique]